[Music]
we have been waiting for someone worthy
of our attention the show is about to
hit and about to be seen how is it felt
to work on a show that is so female
driven which is just too awesome it is
very empowering and honestly it's about
time you know and we're very very proud
to be part of that and it will look good
because Sonique were the cast everyone
has worked so hard and what's so
beautiful here
now the fans are very obsessive and Star
Trek have you had any weird fan
encounters yet not weird really just
very expressively happy I mean when I
arrived they were shouting my name so I
went all the way across and I had a few
Asian friends girls all dressed up as
Captain George already so it's such a
huge compliment I thank them now the
show is streaming which means it can be
a little bit racier than maybe if the
original was what difference is what we
see I can't tell you you have to watch
for yourself it will be it will be
surprising that will be twists and turns
it will be a little bit racier maybe a
little bit more than you expect
we'll see what about nods to the
original how would you describe the way
the show pays homage to the original I
think everybody pays homage to the
original because they are the original
right and so the essence the spirit of
how we started out with Gene Roddenberry
is very much there it's about inclusion
is about loser you know embracing of
diversity reflecting on what's happening
with us
human race and going forward with
strength and compassion so it is all
there and I think this is the the real
spirit of what it is to be Star Trek
[Music]
you